yeah i think we may be pbd
okay sounds good adam tom patrick and a
special guest today
uh you know the word when people drop
the word legendary and i'd be oh he's
such a legend yeah then we dropped that
loosely today's guest is
a person that will be uh full-on
qualified as a legend couple things you
need to know with our yesterday oliver
stone
odds are you have seen you've seen
probably a handful of his work let me
kind of walk through a couple of them
and you tell me he was the writer for
midnight express okay
writer for conan the barbarian writer
for the scarface if you've ever seen
scarface with pacino uh you're the
dragon platoon he was a writer and
director wall street writer and director
born on fourth of july writer director
producer
jfk the movie with kevin costner writer
director producer let me continue
natural born killers writer
and director nixon writer director
producer avida uh any given sunday
alexander do you want to keep going
world trade center w wall street money
never sleeps savages snowden
he's done three documentaries i believe
on castro he had a uh four episode the
interview was 57 58 minutes each with
putin that came out with showtime years
ago good for showtime for actually doing
that
ukraine on fire which i recently watched
and he's got a book
uh that uh somebody i just had a chance
to meet out there who's uh
got the right credibility to say this
she says this may be one of the best
books she's ever read if we can put this
up up there as well so everybody can see
it it's called chasing the light writing
directing
surviving platoon midnight express
scarface salvador and a movie game
oliver stone chasing the light let's put
the link below for people to order as
well having said that oliver stone thank
you so much for being a guest thank you
patrick it's a nice introduction yes
it's great to have you on yeah i also
did in interviews i also did a
documentary a big one with uh hugo
chavez you forgot him oh i forgot that
one well
if if i cover all of them i mean your
your resume is and by the way here's
what's crazy about it everything you're
saying here on top of this like the
stuff that really matters with life
you could have avoided going to vietnam
you didn't
i think you were a school teacher in
saigon i i want to say if i'm saying
that correctly
uh uh you know your upbringing how you
were raised with your father and then
you know finances the debt and his
philosophies and it kind of led you to
your own you went to yale a year later
you dropped out i mean you know you you
have a very rich life
you know we sometimes see the final
product but the coming up to it is
what's really interesting do you mind
taking a uh moment and sharing with the
audience
before oliver stone became oliver stone
that we know about who was oliver stone
a
conforming scared
young student in
school
didn't want to get into trouble
went to boarding school tried to behave
the wild streak was from my mother and
it was in me
but it was buried and
took some time to come out because
i didn't know what i was an only child
so i you have to figure it out step by
step as you know it's not
you don't have an older brother older
sister to teach you the ways
of the world
i i had to i had to bump into the
furniture to to find my my path and i i
suppose it started with their divorce
when i was 16 that was pretty
i thought they were the happiest couple
in the world they were so so beautiful
together my father was i thought he was
rich he was he was on wall street and
they had a beautiful marriage she was
french and he was american he met her in
world war ii during the war and on the
street in the street in paris he picked
her up on a street corner that's
not that she was
not that she was a hooker she was on a
bicycle and he stopped her and
thank you for clarifying that mr stone
and he was
anyway uh that divorce set me on a path
of
aloneness because my family life with
three people it disintegrates when you
don't have
you're so i went off to boarding school
and then from there to saigon
no to yale and at yale i i i was not
happy there was the same environment as
a boarding school and i found that the
entire socio-economic drift of the of
the college was towards
wall street towards capitalism towards
competitiveness uh
it was not about it you know put it this
way in my class at yale was george bush
okay
george bush was a c student at yale
he admits it
but he was entitled and that was a sense
of entitlement that i saw in boarding
school in many people and also in at
yale so there were no women at that
point either it was
i dropped out
i dropped out and went to teach as you
say in saigon in cholon actually to
chinese
vietnamese chinese students huge classes
i taught for two semesters
and it was fascinating experience to be
there
and living in the back alleys and
getting used to a country i didn't know
i didn't know a soul there so it was for
me
an eye-opening experience
came back
eventually in the merchant marine i was
i was a wiper i went on i joined i
always wanted to go to sea so i joined
the as a wiper they allowed me to go not
as a union
because you can get a card when they
when this
these ships were going over to saigon
they were losing the crews because the
guys were jumping crews to make money in
saigon there was a lot of money to be
made
in combat zones so people were jumping
ship and i i sailed back on an empty
ship to coos bay oregon and then i
i i re-enrolled uh at yale out to yale
for my sophomore year dropped out a
second time
dropped our second second so one time
wasn't enough sucked out a second time
okay god i really was it was clear that
i had no future here and i i cut out on
my own wrote a book called child's night
dream which
was finally published in 1997 by uh
saint martins uh and it's a very very
much a 19-year-old's book
very much written in a very romantic
it's embarrassing i mean but i put it
out the way it was written i when i made
some edits but i i just wanted it to be
in the voice of an authentic 19 year old
because we don't listen to 19 year olds
we don't listen to young people young
people have problems
some of them are very suicidal as you
know and and i want and i confront these
these nightmares i had them
you were having suicidal thoughts at 19.
oh yeah really very much so yeah do you
know the divorces before the war right
divorce was successful
that's what i'm saying was it divorced
alienation i didn't know what to do in
my life i was lost really lost
which is i'm trying to explain why i
actually volunteered to go to this
vietnam
combat because it was the only there was
nothing else for me it was the way to
maybe solve this issue if i was going to
off myself i didn't want to do it it
would be done
perhaps for me by the forces you know in
vietnam
so i was willing to you know willing to
die i thought
when i got there of course you know
after infantry training i got pretty i
got put into the 25th infantry and
in uh september of 67 so it was right as
the war was getting to its hottest point
and i i served in three different units
i ended up at the first cavalry because
i got wounded twice in the 25th
i went through the all the stuff in
south saigon then i went up to an
k and then i moved on to camp evans
in kuang tree province
so i had quite a bit of experience there
and so i saw a fair share of combat and
uh came back to the states
as
disillusioned i suppose very
disillusioned i realized i wanted to
live because i didn't want to i didn't i
saw a lot of death and i didn't want to
die
uh
you you said something earlier to me
before we talked about i've yet when i
said something about vietnam i came back
deadened
numb
i didn't know who i was what i was that
was
totally it's a problem for returning
veterans as you know in any war any
place you know
our society was not geared to war our
society people were not
enlisting or
volunteering by any means most people
were avoiding it in my class
at yale and
hill school
all of these people would most of them
were not going there
it was considered
that was for uh poor people right and
that really that bothered me so i got my
first real strong experience of living
with the
call it the lower class americans but
they were really good people and i had
had much there were many good people
there and at the same time i got to know
our black population pretty pretty well
because
i found them to be very powerful in my
experience there they uh in a way they
they helped keep me alive kept me human
the music going back to the base camp
smoking dope that kind of stuff in the
rear is very important and keeps you
it keeps you human and i've discovered
soul music and it was just a good
relationships
whereas
some other people have problems over
there they they
you can let ward you can let war finish
you off it makes you very callous
very careless
it was a racist war in the sense yeah
many many of us mistreated the
vietnamese didn't look didn't respect
him at all the soldiers you mean yeah
yeah
so and that was it you see that overall
in our
attitudes towards third world people
and i saw a lot of that i didn't like it
at all
so
i'm giving you a long narrative no this
is i wrote a book about it it's called
uh
chasing the light and
about my first 40 years and i i told
that story because vietnam plays a huge
role in in america's destiny which is
where i'm going to go to in the in my
lifetime my father being a republican
uh being pro-vietnam at one point uh
very much he was an intelligent man he
wasn't a he was an economist a wall
street man
he uh he
he was very passionate in his views and
he stated them publicly he was a writer
and today among other things he was he
wrote a monthly monthly investment
letter for his firm
and it was a very popular letter so he
was given the gift of expression he was
a very good writer
i admired him
didn't agree with him we fought like dog
and cat after the war because he he
didn't really respect to vietnam he to
him world war ii was the war he was a
lieutenant colonel
you understand the dichotomy and here i
was a pot-smoking long-haired hippie
type coming back from this war but i
wasn't a hippie i was just
a screwed up
veteran you know
so
after a long period of drugs and this
and that i ended up back at nyu on the
gi bill
which is where uh i went to film school
and because what else you know what else
could i do
didn't have any skills except
how to how to fire a rifle how to how to
build a fire how to live outdoors in the
jungle that was those were my skills
so i went to uh
school for the for two years uh marty
scorsese was the youngest teacher there
i had him in a class and he was very
very he moved me
all the teachers were very good school
was very sharp
learned a lot
and wait how much how much further you
want me to go yeah keep i'm actually
very interested please continue i'm
actually very interested in martin
you were scorsese marty was a t yeah he
was young
i want to know to the point of first
movie like i want to know to the point
of your first big movie and then winning
uh
an award for midnight
well that's a few years ahead i had to
go through a lot of
to a lot of uh rejection
from film school i mean you come out of
film school i was driving i drove a taxi
in new york
uh because that was there's
there was no jobs for phil it wasn't
younger people were not yet accepted the
way they have been since uh it was tough
i drove a taxi it was a messenger i was
working in all temp jobs that i could
get
and i was writing i i kept writing i
remember i written a novel so i kept
writing screenplays my first screenplay
is 69
and it's a crazy it reads crazy but it's
part of the development of a writer you
have to go through all these i wrote
eight nine ten maybe eleven screenplays
over those next six seven years
and all of them were rejected
although two of them were finally
optioned
and that led to some kind of light
in in hollywood i started to meet some
people just off the options
matt had married a lebanese woman
uh who was very beautiful and
had a job at the un so i was she was
helping me uh uh
i was living in her apartment we were
married and
nashua
lebanese i'm sure you you know uh
christian lebanese so uh
i i moved to hollywood
we divorced after seven years
together we and i moved to hollywood
and started over again i was very lucky
in the sense that
my first i got a job a higher job to
work on midnight express which was a
book
peter a big uh a hustling young producer
peter guber
at columbia wanted to make this movie
and
and of course the story was fascinating
about a turk a boy american boy from
long island was busted in turkey
and for hash
went to jail for uh
was sentenced to 30 years but uh it was
quite a case and it went around and
around no it was first of all he was
sentenced for five years and then he was
resentenced for 30 years
the turkish system of justice at that
time was very strange
uh and the the jail was hilarious
because
if you had money in jail in turkey you
lived like a king but if you were just
part of the foreign riff raf
uh you lived pretty badly yeah
so uh you can imagine the contrast
uh anyway the movie came out and it was
a gigantic hit
it was 1978 79.
and i got an academy award that was the
most shocking crazy yeah with the way to
get you know you know what makes you
interesting
um
you know sometimes we're uncomfortable
to tell our story it's like look it's
not that big of a deal it's my life
where you know we're just telling our
life story
um
here's what makes you very unique as an
artist and i don't know if the world
appreciates you as much as they do and
i'll unpack my opinion on how i view you
okay
um
so
for somebody to have
the amount of life you know acting is
what to to to draw from a certain place
you were at in your life to get into
that emotion or reacting you know
there's different kind of acting but a
person who's more well-rounded they can
go and explain a scene better because
they can go there right so
background that republican economist
conservative
then he loses debt divorce you can draw
from what it is to be a father
republican conservative then you
experience a kid divorced 16 years old
heartbroken what it is to have that take
place mom french so you learn the
history of french because mom's going to
pass that down to you then you go
military so you have a little bit of
that experience from the military you go
to see exactly what's going on in
vietnam i mean you draw from that for a
movie which leads later on to platoon
which i don't know how many times i
watch platoon when i was in the army
then you're talking about yale to be
around people like bush who come from
families of strong lineage and they get
to go there so you see what parties they
can participate in and you can't and how
that privileged life is like than being
a teacher your compassion for the africa
african-american black community and
then coming up i mean the
the amount of things you can draw from
and you tell the story we feel it
meaning we be in the audience
we see your final product we don't
we see what you're putting together so
it's it's impressive and one of the
things that i appreciate about your work
is the fact that look
today we had a doctor here on and we're
having a conversation with them and and
i remember years ago when i got enamored
by jfk what happened with them all of a
sudden i'm like i gotta interview i
watch your documentary jfk and obviously
i've seen a movie i've seen a lot of
that stuff but last time i'm watching a
documentary
and abraham bouldin i remember when we
interviewed him five years ago or clint
hill or rfk or
you know cyril wecht cyril and i had a
phenomenal interview together because i
want to know that story
but you also it this is what it comes
across to me i think young filmmakers
who are not afraid who have audacity
and they have the guts to do
what an artist ought to do and and we
ought to let this person do what they're
doing is
it seems like you're the kind of guy
that if you are looking at castro and
nobody's saying stuff about castro like
look i don't know what you think you
hate them you love them you can't stand
them you could care less about them
i wanted to learn that's what i wanted i
don't want to judge i want to learn okay
you this putin guy is a horrible person
great okay let's say you're right people
from russia some of them love them some
of them hate them i don't know you know
what hey can we do an interview i want
to learn right hey this ukraine thing
everything i hear about with ukraine you
know
love them hate them you know the battle
of victors and all this other stuff i
don't know i want to learn i think the
courage you have
to go touch some of the subjects that
the rest of the world is like well
fox news said this they must be right
cnn said this they must be right msnbc
said this they must be right new york
post said that they must be our new york
times said they must be right you're
like yeah i don't know if i believe
anyone i kind of want to find out for
myself that takes a lot of courage to do
what you you what you've done
that's what's impressive i think our
stories are similar because what you
told me is you came from a very
from syria iran born and raised in but
my dad was in syria my mother was
armenian
so you've been you've been you're the
you're the ultimate too you're a refugee
from those situations and you you're in
this country which is a big open
freeway in many ways and a
marketplace of ideas but you're open and
you want to see you want to learn that
was what happened to me and i and i'm
still on that journey and i'm 75 years
old i'm still can't i'd love to know
more i'd like to
so many people i'd like to meet but it's
you know the the
rigidity and the orthodoxy is what
always
close you down they always limit you
constantly all my life
uh you know my father at first you know
he's certainly didn't approve of my my
thoughts about
the war and this and
and certainly i started to question
economics
you know he was a big franklin roosevelt
he was not he was he was there in the
1930s he was there in the depression he
despised roosevelt and i had that most
of my childhood but as i got into
american history more and more and
really studied it i went back
not in school years later with my
project untold history of the united
states it's a 12-part history i think
it's i'm very proud of it
it took five years to put that together
with peter koznik a historian who taught
me
had me read the right books and think
about american history in a completely
different way than i thought of it
before and that's the result of that and
among and roosevelt is very much a
pillar in that movie and so is john
kennedy
it becomes more and more apparent the
more you read about mr kennedy that he
was truly in that same tradition of
roosevelt being open-minded to other
people very much as an irishman
anti-colonial
very much so oh had a much more deeper
relationship with africa with indonesia
with south america and with nasser and
egypt than we know oh nasser was
heartbroken when yeah but yeah there was
a he was working very
effectively to re-establish american
relations with these countries
in sukarno and indonesia and he was
changing the policy in vietnam
unfortunately he didn't live long enough
to to get it done
because lyndon johnson who was supposed
to be his transition was went in a
complete u-turn in a different direction
immediately which american historians do
not admit so here again this is an
interesting we've come across orthodoxy
in history too
and in our thinking and in our media
and that's always been my problem coming
up against that and being criticized for
that for challenging those views is is
that because the natural like you know
how we grow up like the one person you
never question as your father that if
you eventually were like i don't know if
my dad's right and i'm gonna go figure
it out for myself like that is still
with you at 75 where today father maybe
the president or the government or the
media or whatever you like
yeah i there's got to be something more
to it is that kind of your mindset
there's got to be something more to it
than what i'm hearing
well my mother has come plays a huge
role here because my mother was a rebel
we haven't talked much about her she was
she was a rebel part of the reason the
divorce was what it was is that she
rebelled against the system
she didn't want to live inside that
box where the man has adult commits
adultery all the time and the woman
doesn't so she broke her she made her
own rules up and she had fun she was
quite a liver uh and she was quite a
deliverer and a hedonist and many
friends she was loved by so many people
i can't tell you and i think that's a
great quality to have opposites as
parents wow
not to say my father wasn't funny he was
also very funny but it wasn't like they
were
she had a different spirit and rebelled
all the time
she had lived through the occupation
nazi occupation
in paris in world war ii so she was uh
she she really appreciated
the freedom uh
that after a war
and uh
a very loving person
so she's in my she's in my heart
she's always there
but uh i take from both of them both
parents are very strong later on did you
ever kind of think and say you know
i used to uh not agree with my dad on
these two things you know
now that i'm 52 years old this one part
that i disagree with my dad i agree with
him he was right here and he was right
here and
he was wrong there and she was wrong
there and she was right did that happen
sure oh yeah was there anything specific
people that's what life is like my my
mother because of my father became
a republican she supported you know
reagan and
all that but she didn't really it was
all
you know inside that she was a free
spirit got it and totally uh
and frankly uh john kennedy my father
was skeptical about him didn't preferred
nixon
and uh me too at that point it took me a
long you have to learn for yourself
that's what the whole point of life is
it's your it's your it's your path to
learn if you don't change if you're
still the same person you were when you
were young
well you might like it but
it doesn't show that you have tried
other states of being
pat what's the one thing you always say
about first you love your parents then
you begin to disagree with them and then
eventually you start to humanize them
what do you always call idolize
demonize human eyes yeah that's the
three phases you go through parenting
yeah that's pretty well said idolize uh
demonize human eyes you know
but there's three topics i'd want to
touch upon with you one of them is
obviously
jfk
uh because
again i couldn't stop watching that
thing the other thing is a little bit on
the ukraine on fire documentary and your
interview with putin since it's relevant
whatever comments you may have on that
and then a couple other topics before we
wrap up first one being jfk this is just
again selfishly for me i can't i can't
uh uh stop reading enough content or
studying this guy enough and
you know you look at rfk said something
very unique in the interview where he
says in the documentary where he said
there is no man where there is more
statues building streets named after him
then kenneth jfk right now i've seen
churchill maybe there are a couple other
names maybe there but you know kennedy
being what he did but
why why uh
why the level of interest in his story
what caused you to say i really want to
investigate the story even more
well history is crucial because if lest
you know where you came from
you don't know where you are i mean it
becomes
in a sense america is
not really agreed on its history and
that's one of the reasons i did this
untold history
we don't we have a lot of mythology in
our country there's a myth about america
there's a myth about america and there
are facts
and in our history we tried to bring out
facts that we don't deal with we don't
even know
so that's why it's called untold it's
there it's known but it's been hidden
and of course among the all these many
facts is the fact that you know among
others is world war ii which is still
partly motivating our ideology in the
world that there's a hitler out there
and that we're all and we're the
defenders of freedom and democracy is a
large is is also a myth in the sense
that we did not win world war ii we had
the russians were the ones who broke
their back and took the most casualties
and actually tore the guts out of the
german war machine
and churchill said so himself
they were the sacrifice
27 million people died
many of them eight 10 million were
military their their casualties were so
much higher than ours and four fifths of
the german uh military machine was
destroyed on the eastern front
one-fifth in the west so by the time
d-day happened in uh 1944
and we landed and it was a great big
myth but that that was that was late in
the war by 43 the war was turning and
early 44. because it was after after
stalingrad the russians had turned and
it was starting to chase the russians
starting to chase the germans out of
russia it's a huge important point that
this
part of this history that's distorted
and then of course i i go to the place
where jfk is killed
and i
try to explain in these documentaries
why he was killed that's the most
important question what was the reason
what would be the benefit of it what
would change after he was killed and if
you look at the record
aside from civil rights lyndon johnson
changed pretty much everything that
kennedy was doing he cut off
relationships with with africa with the
middle east with indonesia with vietnam
he became another kind of creature the
old-fashioned way of doing business from
eisenhower and dulles brothers that is
without doubt and we go into some length
to to make this point to the american
public they have to learn this you have
to watch the uh you've seen the
four-hour version so you know there's
more history there and the two-hour
version is called revisited the
four-hour version is called destiny
betrayed
uh they're both available the four hours
available on uh
on
uh shout factory
and it's also available on you can rent
it on i think amazon
or and no you have to buy it actually
it's a digital purchase because it just
came out yesterday it's gonna be on
itunes it'll be on apple can i get it
there's two of them that one and the
other one they did with the the nation
the twelve episodes i'll get i'll watch
both of those the twelve episodes is
untold history that was 2012.
but that has some great stuff on world
war ii and and the cold war the cold war
as well as up to the iraq war go go go
to to what you said so you said the real
reason to do the documentary to see why
like the whole the why right okay so for
you like did you catch yourself going on
a rabbit hole and and saying you know
because i interviewed the mobsters
gangsters samudable michael francis
frank colada then i went to to clint
hill who was the secret service agent to
jackie to see what he had to say and you
know and then i went to abraham bolden
who was the first black african-american
secret service agent and then i went to
cyril wecht who was one of the what do
you call him the a person who wha what
do you call certain jobs
yeah and then jim and all these things
i'm doing so i went down the rabbit hole
to find kind of figure out but for you
what when you're by yourself and the
whole thing is done and you watch it
what are you thinking who do you think
was afraid of revealing the truth about
what happened with uh kennedy is it ciao
was that your final conclusion when you
see that these huge changes these are
youth changes in foreign and domestic
policy except for civil rights that's
the only just uh as you know kennedy
submitted the bill a civil rights court
yep and it was very beautiful on his
momentum beautiful speech and based on
the momentum of his death johnson
finally got it passed that was the
beginning of and they make johnson into
a hero but he's not a hero because those
people who say this was a smooth
transition are dead wrong it's rubbish
really rubbish kennedy was killed for a
reason and you have to look at the
highest levels of our society
who would hate him or resist him he was
disliked we know for a civil rights
stance in the south george wallace said
that he would not win the south in the
64 election we know that he had
he said quite openly after the bay of
pigs
and after the missile crisis he avoided
war twice with cuba this is serious he
avoided two wars the second one the
missile crisis could have been the war
that ended mankind that was a huge
nuclear confl potentially conflict
to save this country from two wars is
this to me is as important as what the
russians did in world war ii because if
they hadn't done what they had done we
would have american casualties which
were 450 000 might well have been two
three million
more just to get through the hitler the
fortress that hitler had built in in
europe
it's a big deal my father could have
been killed your fathers we wouldn't
even be here people don't unders they
they agree there's a there's a easy
presumption that we're alive and we we
can we have these choices but we
wouldn't even be alive to make those
choices
so uh i'm very my gratitude is enormous
to to both the soviet union and to
to john kennedy who uh was killed
because he wouldn't go to war against
cuba now the vietnam thing they they
accuse me of that one too but it's been
proven correct
mr mcnamara is the secretary of defense
mcgeorge bundy his national securities
advisor have since written books since
my movie came out saying that he was
going to pull out of vietnam win or lose
win or lose
mcnamara was very clear about that in
his book in retrospect
uh and you have to understand these are
people they were hawks at that time of
vietnam
so they they're not interested in saying
they're admitting that i was they were
wrong they're saying kennedy really was
clear about it but that he couldn't
announce it publicly he couldn't make a
big deal of it because he had to get
elected he was going to run against
barry goldwater who was
a hawk
right you have to be in america you
can't get elected unless you're a tough
guy
have you ever heard that perspective
before what he's saying is is
contradictory to basically what every
american has ever known which part the
part specifically about world war ii
we've been you know the greatest
generation is the name that everyone
uses for the parents of the baby boomers
they they fought in world war ii
one-fifth west 45th east the royal
russia play that cost them is that is
that what you're talking precisely and
ultimately we've been raised that the
greatest generation of all time is the
world war ii generation you know the
baby bomber they raided the no the
parents of the the baby boomers they
raided the streets of nor the shores of
normandy and this is the epitome of
american culture and exceptionalism
and
your father fought in this war what kind
of backlash do you get from your father
or your father's you know constituency
his age from what you're saying about
world war ii very key question and yeah
would you mind just pulling this closer
to you because i yeah you can even move
that
i'm saying you can grab that like like
this
you're saying to move the mic
because what you're saying is very
important and it's contradictory to
anything we've ever heard about america
that's a great question
well thank you adam but
the
the concept
of the greatest generation is mythology
again it was invented as far as i know
by uh ambrose stephen ambrose who's a
a certain kind of historian very
patriotic
i believe it was ambrose but certainly
tom brokaw who uh interviewed me
uh made also
i remember him
using that expression and he wrote a
book about it
tom legend
now tom brokaw is a very nice liked
very much liked on the air but he is not
a very bright man in my opinion he
interviewed me on the kennedy
assassination for an hour and a half in
this
2013 the 60th anniversary i talked to
him very cogently as i'm talking now for
an hour and a half he he
they when they when they when they
released the uh the documentary
it was i was there for 60 seconds and it
was very superficial that's the kind of
treatment you get in major media in the
united states you know they cut to the
commercial
you can't have any serious discussion on
the air this is
this is so bad this is part of our
problem we don't think about things we
don't discuss
both sides of an equation
but the greatest generation is is a lie
and they would
they point to george
h.w bush oh he was he was a fighter
pilot he was a heroic man yes but what
look what happened he goes to war in
iraq
on the flimsiest of reasons
and
there's a lot of doubts about that 1990
war and then we can go into that but not
here uh
and he's he was made a giant a lion of
that generation but he's not he's not he
was a he's a man who did his job in
world war ii and it was a tough war no
question about it but a lot of those
people if you go and talk to the actual
people who fought in the war will tell
you another story completely how filthy
and dirty it was and how
i won't use
it was an obscenity it's a podcast you
can you can
it was not a pretty war it was
no one's proud of their service no and
they civilians are killed all the time
all kinds of cowardice all kinds of
infighting among the troops
the truth of war is that
and so we we have some kind of
you know the problem now we've sanitized
since vietnam we've sanitized the news
about war right you get embedded you
have to have journalists embedded safely
with the military in order to report
anything you're not allowed to show the
bodies coming back they hide them
iraq
and
afghanistan
we've sanitized tried to sanitize the
war now we're not even using troops
we're trying to use proxy nations and
send their armies to fight
so i i
we have to re-examine that
attitude that we have that we're number
one we have to learn to live with other
nations
learn to cooperate
we don't have to be the most dominant
nation in the world i think we'd be
better off if we were quieter and a
little and let other countries have
their power balances we need a balance
of power between people between
countries too
as in a family yeah
you know going back to it when you were
talking about the we were talking about
the jfk
uh documentary
there's a there's a part of it where
uh the
the ci agent they're talking about
oswald and a part of it in the story uh
where in the documentary they're talking
about the other agent whose name is uh
thomas arthur
vale right thomas arthur valley very
interesting where it shows
you know they were have couple other
attempts on this assassination on
kennedy one of them being november 2nd
in chicago the other one being november
18 in tampa and he's supposed to go on
this 27 mile you know yeah
and then they say you shouldn't do this
this valet guy
ex-marine oswald ex-marine
uh was at the japan base he's at the
japan base he trained another base there
but in japan cia cuba training same here
he was at a six or seven story building
almost identical to the building
and then the entire time all this is
going on and i'm talking to jim jenkins
i said jim let me ask you a question who
like who do you think was behind this
who do you think caused all of this
and i'm asking them names i said what do
you think about lyndon johnson
and he says i i don't
trust lyndon johnson i said tell me why
so you know the story behind lyndon
johnson being way more ambitious than
john f kennedy and he was so upset with
the fact that these guys took office and
behind closed doors so
from your end when you were doing the
investigation i know jfk wanted to get
rid of cia and lyndon johnson wanted to
go vietnam john f kennedy didn't want to
go vietnam you know these things that
they had
how much d i felt like that documentary
could have gone a little bit deeper on
lbj's motivation what did you learn
about lbj at the end this is a very good
question and i'm
reluctant to point at johnson for the
for the murder as i said at the time in
1991 i do believe totally he was
responsible for the cover-up
because the cover he starts with the
warren commission he does everything
possible and he if you saw that you
remember the documentary
there's even a scene when he's talking
to mcmahon you hear the phone
conversation where he says i didn't
agree with you and the president that we
should that we should uh
pull out of vietnam
he's very very pointed so he i don't
think though he wanted to go to vietnam
i think that
that was on the agenda because we had
already started the process of vietnam
with eisenhower not with kennedy with
eisenhower we started the process of
supporting the french paying for the
french war
so kennedy
fell into the trap he'd sent advisers
not combat troops but he insisted no
combat troops he insisted to the very
end he insisted no combat troops go to
laos either no combat troops are going
to go to cuba that's the reason baya
pigs
he was hated by the cuban community
after two three years of this he refused
to fight send american troops into cuba
kennedy unknown what war was knew what
it meant he'd been on that pt boat he'd
seen all the
he been at the lower level and he knew
he didn't believe the generals he he saw
the fallacy of this belief that the
generals know everything
he comes into office the first thing
he's presented with is eisenhower's
psyop plan siop
62 siop 62 to blow up the world
there is a plan you know that they were
going to attack china and moscow russia
first and the first strike option was
also on the table it still is in the
united states the first strike option is
still on the table and very much a
consideration in this ukraine debate by
the way because
certainly that's one of the things the
russians fear the most is encirclement
and nato
and
nuclear
nuclear nuclear arms in the polish
romanian and possibly ukrainian hands
there it is single integrated
operational plan it's a wicked plan and
it was devised by people who were
basically paranoid you saw the movie dr
strangelove you saw the military people
as pictured there
can i read this to the audience
recording the single interrogator
this was the united states general plan
for nuclear war from 1961 to 2-3 gave
the president united states a range of
targeting options and described launch
procedures and targets said against the
nuclear weapons would be launched to
plan integrate the capabilities of
nuclear retire in terms of everything so
interesting
this is a system this is an industry
this is not just a plan this is a
business
of billions of dollars how much have we
spent since
1947 on our
defense
it's out of proportion to anything we
really needed for our defense
it's basically to to dominate the world
to have 800 bases in every country
practically we can in the world
and it's a gigantic operation but a lot
of people contractors
uh raython
lockheed martin
make a fortune on this thing a fortune
on this business so
to close this down to start to reduce it
it's the hardest thing to do in the
world since jack kennedy was president
no american president has gone close to
even
trying to interfere with with the
military with that system to really cut
back
or at the same time with the interfered
with the intelligence agencies of this
country remember he said very clearly
after the bay of pigs because they had
given him false information and they
betrayed him there he said i'm gonna
we're gonna destroy i'd like to
i'd like to i'd like to uh shatter the
cia and and
scatter it to the winds i forgot the
exact quote but he certainly made the
effort he fired alan dulles who was the
head of the cia was a respected revered
figure from the 1950s under eisenhower
his brothers john foster dulles
secretary of state who set this policy
not of neutrality but of
rollback it wasn't even
containment had been the american policy
towards communism rollback this is what
uh dulles wanted and he want
brinksmanship he believed in
brinksmanship and he and that's what was
going on right now the same people are
back in the state department and giving
that kind of advice to joe biden
but okay we're there now again this
we're potentially in another
cuban missile crisis potentially
going back to this system that existed
kennedy was trying to change it and the
moment he went killed the whole thing
changes we keep going all the presidents
they they're they're puppets basically
they they they operate within a certain
parameter they can't touch the two most
important things are the intelligence
agencies and the military industrial do
you two have a similar opinion on who
actually killed jfk
yeah well we haven't gone there yet
what is your opinion i'm curious well
my opinion is is based on what
years of thinking about it but frankly
it can't johnson was a weakling compared
to what we're dealing with here
johnson was a loser he was a vice
president and uh he had a lot of scandal
in his life so he was not in a position
of great strength
which makes him all the more suspect as
a but he
he would have been very suspect if he
something had happened to kennedy
he
the people who did this
have to be at the very top of the
society they had to be cia
and the only people i could really think
work are the dulles people because he
was the king of the cia
and he had although he had been fired he
was still in washington and he was very
active his people were still there
kennedy fired bissell and
and cabell but the whole
people left in the ci you have to clean
out the whole agency as harriman said
that
you cannot leave those people in place
richard helms became the new
traffic cop he became the new real head
mccone was appointed but he was a
figurehead
helms and and that gang were still there
and those are the guys you really gotta
look at because they were
moving the oswalds around the map to
russia that this is what dulles did they
they had they had a program angleton was
another guy james eigel who ran that
program
putting american defectors into russia
for information we wanted land-based
information we wanted
we didn't we had to spy uh we had uh
u2 flights and all that but they wanted
people on the ground they sent over
quite a few defectors
how'd they get how'd they get there and
how they came back is a very interesting
story and of course oswald is hardly
examined he's
he's also given money it's just a
strange strange story we go into it the
fingerprints of intelligence are all
over oswald
it's very clear from uh if you watch
these uh
even the two hour will make that very
clear yeah so if you have that
intelligence but even at that level
dulles would not have been
dulles had to be given the go-ahead by
someone else and who the only people i
can think of is the people who basically
run this country basically east coast
financial people from the establishment
and that goes to a high level that
doesn't mean everybody they're not
sitting around at a conference room it
just means he has to have a conversation
is it okay is it okay this president is
a problem he's he's
antagonized big business uh with the
steel price hike
he's made it very clear his
pacifist tendencies
and he's getting along with
these third world countries he's
anti-colonial
very much the irish rebel
this is going to be a problem because
he's going to get elected in 64. and
then his brother his brother robert
who's a tough guy he thought he fought
the mob he's going to come in 60 and 72
potentially
76. and then there's this other younger
brother teddy who was already in the
senate and he's going to be next could
be a dynasty they're scared of roosevelt
roosevelt had been there for
16 15 years
15 years of roosevelt this they were
scared a lot of these people were shaken
like my father they didn't want to see
another
renaissance of democratic rule
people's rule they don't believe in
people's democracy they don't believe
the people should run the country no
they want control and
you so that's the whole thing the
eisenhower and reagan are so
anti-roosevelt they they all their
policies are gradually dismantling the
new deal and you see that through the
whole 1980s 90s even now we have some
remnants of the new deal which i think
are very good but they're going to be
under fire they're going to be under
threat
oliver how different is how different is
uh what was going on then versus now
because i so so for me i watched two
documents i watched ukraine on fire i
watched winter on fire so winter on fire
was the one sean penn talks about it on
fire yours is ukraine on fire there's
another one that
and so i watch both of them because i
want to kind of get a feeling
winter on fire is more about the
students the revolution hey victor
agreed yes we're going to sign the eu
agreement we're going to go with them
everything's going to work out overnight
he says no i'm going to go to russia so
the students revolt and they're you know
all those scenes it's very emotional
stuff to watch but you watch that so
then i'm going to go and watch yours
because winter on fire doesn't tell the
history of
ukraine it doesn't tell the history of
what
stefan bandera did
and how 80 000 ukrainian ukrainian
soldiers represented and fought for
hitler and then they put him in jail and
then you know the the two victors
battling and the role russia played it
was a very interesting way of seeing
ukraine on fire what what did you learn
about ukraine and russia when you did
the documentary ukraine on fire
uh because we're in it right now we're
into this also
there's antecedents you get among other
things you should go back to world war
ii and you should understand that
there's a split in the ukraine and that
part half of ukraine is russian-speaking
the other half
is anti-russian strongly so
uh stephen bandera and people like that
uh were working with the nazis
many groups uh the ukrainians were
uh uh hunting jews in
in ukraine and in uh poland there was a
lot of killing going on it was a dirty
bloody war so much
stuff happened that
so
you have all these people they never
went away they're still there in the
ukraine if you look at the maidan
the maidan moment and you look at our
film you'll see very clearly the nazi
the neo-nazis are back the azov
battalion the idaho battalion uh the
right sector party and and you see them
on camera and they're very rough
customers these people they're not about
to be they don't believe in democracy
they don't yeah there was a lot of
students and a lot of honest people in
my dad and there was a lot of
frustration with the corruption
in ukraine
but
we go into the whole history of that
relationship of
the president with the eu he tried to
make a deal with the eu he had a better
economic deal from russia that's that's
the reason he stayed he didn't sign on
to the eu deal very important to
recognize that he wanted to postpone it
until he got a better deal and that
makes sense too
when all this was happening in my dan he
even offered to have an earlier election
he offered it he said
if you want to okay you want to get rid
of me it's not democratic but we'll
we'll go with an earlier election
and they actually accepted it but then
the these thugs who are operating behind
the scenes
at maidan
very organized by the way very organized
i think the cia plays another role there
because cia has been involved with
ukrainian nazis since world war ii we
got a lot of them out to our country on
the rat lines and we came back
after world war ii and 48 there was a
an operation by the cia to drop these
people into ukraine to make trouble to
start uh troubles for uh russia
it's an old story it's not new you know
this is but i don't think a lot of
people know it though well it's an it's
a fact in fact the guy i worked with on
jfk fletcher prouty was a colonel who
was in world war ii and air force and he
was one of those guys who supplies these
these uh uh infiltration infiltrators to
the ukraine with weapons
and with flights and you have to drop
them and so forth and so on it's a lot
of hardware all these guys were picked
up by the way that's what's amazing that
orange it's like with castro whenever we
go up against castro he seems to find
out the people we send in uh secretly
it's an interesting side effect but the
russians picked up
the russian ukraine picked up these
people
but we tried to destroy
russia by any chance do you know if your
phone is on because someone's ring is
going oh i'm doing this you mean i know
is your phone on do you have your phone
with you maybe it's your phone going on
because someone's phone's going off
i have it with me but i
check to see if maybe if it's going up
okay uh just the ringtone no it's
nothing okay sounds good so it's off so
so so so now if we watch tv today and we
turn it on you you're seeing that
that is standing and he's you know
looking pretty strong and tough and he's
not you know reacting and the news is
telling us that russia's lost five to
six thousand soldiers uh in the last few
weeks which is more than what we lost in
iraq and
you know the the two foreign ministers
had a conversation together two three
days ago it was an hour and a half
conversation in turkey nothing uh no
advancements really made
how different is ukraine's story today
versus when you did the documentary how
much has changed because zelinski is not
in your documentary when you did it
right so is it night and day different
story today are they making more
problems we didn't no it's not me who
did it
the director was igor lapatonic who was
ukrainian
russian ukrainian and he did it i was an
interviewer and a one of the producers
so
these two films ukraine on fire and
the other one is called uh ukraine
revealed
revealed goes into the present moment
with zelinski there
it's a very interesting documentary
about the opposition candidate victor
medvedek medvedchuk
victor medvedchuk
revealing ukraine that's it
robert perry was one of the great
journalists in our country it was the
most eloquent about ukraine and and saw
this coming he was talking about a
nuclear conflict back in 2014
when this thing went down he saw it
coming he died in 2015 it's a great loss
to american journalism he was the
truth-teller
this story is today is so passionate and
so complicated all the news in america
unfortunately is
is one-sided you don't get anything from
the other side there's no and they
banned it they banned rt and they banned
right they had a very concerted campaign
to cut off what they call russian
disinformation is perhaps the best
information we can get from what's
really going on
and i frankly i don't have all the
details i do hear the other side because
i read alternate media which is to say
what's available on the internet they're
not going to be able to kill off all
that
because there are a lot of american
journalists who are aware of this and
writing about it there are people who
actually been in donbass and can tell
you that in from 2014 to now donbass has
been victimized by
the ukrainian army and especially by the
nazis
the neo-nazi gangs they're the ones
who've been dropping the artillery
killing people
it's been a bloody and it's hard there's
estimated 16 000 dead
most of them on the russian side most of
them uh don bass people
okay and that is never dealt with you
don't hear about it in the u.s media can
you pull up donves on the map by the way
a lot of them have immigra because of
the bombings they move they immigrated
to russia across the border
and uh you don't hear about that you'll
hear about refugees only going to the
other side from this war i don't think
it's
listen i don't know what putin had putin
pune
was squeezed he was provoked into this
thing and that's the truth the united
states has using ukraine as an as a
proxy
to put pressure they don't us doesn't
care about ukraine they care about
russia this is a chance to destabilize
russia remove the leader regime change
once again on a big on a big way this is
a big victory for them if they can pull
it off
and this was always the gold from the
beginning i i don't think there's any
concern about the ukrainian people
except as a sentimental thing in the
newspaper as well this person was killed
that person was killed but what about
the people who were killed on the other
side they never mentioned them for five
six years no more than that eight years
those people were killed too families
were killed
um
you know it's it's crazy what you're
saying so let me let me give you a
different perspective from my from my
life
so when i lived in iran if you turn on
the news in iran we have two channels
uh every president in iran and u.s was
the enemy you heard death upon america
you heard about how big of an enemy
everybody was except for people in iran
so you we were naive we thought khomeini
was the greatest thing since sly spread
we thought khomeini imam khamenei these
guys were all right and the shah was
horrible the shah was a horrible person
in iran i mean if you said anything good
about the sean iran you're a bad person
right so then you come to
we go live in germany and you watch
satins in germany okay satins is like
they're nbc let's just say around you're
watching satins and you're saying who
they paint as being a bad person right
and they're painting the picture of
who's what right then you come to the
states you turn on the news and you hear
who the enemy is right here you know and
then and then eventually you got to get
to a point that either you're going to
follow the masses and if they're
believing what they're believing you got
to question some of it right so
us carter what they did which was uh
seems like very interesting strategy
that they're currently using here as
well this is a very easy playbook to use
is
they used khomeini who was in france
a way to get the shot to be out so
carter goes to iran has a nice little
dinner with the shah december 31st 77
they do a toast gives a toast leaves
revolution happens right off the bat i'm
born in 78 october 18th
kissinger keeps saying we're going to
help you we're going to help you we're
going to help you we're going to help
you then the last thing they tell them
is well how to take you out and he
leaves
you know in january february something
second khomeini takes over and then iran
right away there's a war between iraq
now the u.s doesn't get then there's so
we do we do
we do get involved with the point and
then who makes money the
military-industrial complex you know all
these raytheon north of grumman but but
the point is
that there is there is rarely a way to
know the whole story you just said
something right now that the audience is
going to sit there and say wait us is
using ukraine as a proxy to get to putin
to remove him because now the whole
world hates that guy didn't want to move
him okay
what was your experience like when you
did your interview with putin
yeah
i'll tell you in a second but uh just to
make one more point about iran to me the
whole thing
devolves back to 1953
when they got in the ucia and british
intelligence got rid of mosaddegh he was
the democratic choice for prime minister
he was very popular among most people in
iran and he would have won and he would
have kept going and he nationalized part
after a lot of provocation he
nationalized the oil interests the
british oil interests particularly in
iran that was his
that that was the signal to get rid of
them so they used ci very heavily
involved they they paid money to mobs to
storm the streets to create all these
distractions like they did at maidan to
bring
chaos to the country and then in the
chaos he was called a communist again he
was not a communist because of the
two-day party he did have contacts but
he was not a communist he was more like
a bernie sanders he was he was more of a
socialist he was not accountable he was
a social man he was a great man yeah
he was just too trusting he trusted too
much and
they got rid of him they didn't kill him
but they they've been like they removed
him yeah and they put the shot in again
they'd done that before
and deshaw of course
became more and more of a tyrant and a
lot of torture i went to the prison
there i saw all the the stories of the
torture they're very famous in iran a
lot of people are scared
to open their mouths under the shah and
of course khomeini comes in he was not
the people's choice he was definitely a
counter he was because of the extremism
of the shah that's you get another
extreme reaction to that that always
happens in history it does very rarely
can a moderate emerge in this world
khomeini was extreme and
whatever you you know you know the the
rest of the story
uh
however khomeini did have a lot of
provocation we went on the iran iraq
side of the war we supported iraq
at first
we gave them weapons and then when
reagan wanted help with the contras
in latin america to defeat the
nicaraguan communists
he gave weapons he gave weapons to uh
iran
which is to a khomeini's regime which is
amazing this is 1983
82 right
right off the cardboard dirty story i
mean reagan was a tr
basically had done something that the
worst american i mean
it's traded it's an act a traitor you
mean you're supporting the supposed
enemy
nixon in watergate never did anything
close to what reagan did reagan got away
with it because he was popular in a
sense he had that smile he's a good
performer conjugate is one of the most
undiscovered scandals in american
history country if you should really
read up on it it's a very important
scandal and it comes it comes unglued
and reagan in the last two years of his
life his presidency was unable to
uh was unable to uh
keep his agenda going in fact we would
have been
we would have been in a war in nicaragua
he would have sent troops to nicaragua i
was down in that region
because i was visiting it to make
salvador my first one of my first movies
i was in that region i saw all the
troops in honduras i saw the troops in
el salvador
there was quite there was an operation
about to happen and thank god iran
contra gate was blown
among them was robert perry who blew the
story
changed the direction of the country
briefly
all these things
we we heard about we heard about this
from oliver north he was in all the
hearings looking as a very statesmanlike
colonel that's that was the portrayal
right oliver north was one of the uh
malefactors yes he was one of reagan's
men but
it goes back to reagan he got away with
it north took the fall as do as you know
how many people resigned in iran
conjugate about six people
mcfarland there was a whole bunch of
people who resigned i forgot exactly who
reagan uh
he basically uh skated out of there uh
two years later by the way all these
stories that you're bringing up which
are
and so did george h.w bush bush was
definitely involved in negotiations with
the iranians
he got out too i mean this whole thing
was buried and you have to point to the
washington media here i'm sorry but i'm
just going to finish the story but
washington post plays a huge role here
catherine graham who was the
famous star meryl streep player in the
post miss hero of america all that kind
of stuff she she buried the story she
did not believe after watergate the post
had been involved in watergate she said
i don't think america can take a second
shock like this so she killed it
killed the story there was no coverage
i was just going to say that all these
stories that you're bringing up which
are not easy on the ears if you're
obviously pro-american the one
visualization that i'm having is the
whole scene from trump's interview in
2016 where he famously says
oh you think we're that innocent too
what was the one thing that he said
it's the one honest thing that trump
says you said possibly
okay but it's true i mean essentially
you're taking you're going inside the
underbelly of america the cia and you
know what's happening in the oval office
and you know these secret conversations
and you're bringing and you're shining a
light on them and it's not so pretty
even if you love america it's hard to
digest i love america and i can take
this
i can take the dirt i think that's what
we have to do we have to be truthful and
we can be better people we can on and we
can treat other people with
respect
and understand our limitations as well
it's
why do we have to be top dog is a big
question
well that's that's american
exceptionalism right i mean that's the
concept of capitalism there's
competition that's in the core dna that
we have here this is why america has
40 million immigrants that they want to
come here and have an equal opportunity
to compete in a marketplace and if you
can you can build a great life for
yourself but you can't have a
capitalistic society and then ask people
why are we so competitive to be number
one it's like if you play for the
yankees the yankees don't start the
season saying guys listen let's just
play the game forget about going to play
who cares about the playoffs let's just
win to play the game that's not yankees
nature yankees are starting a season to
say let's crush everybody and win
the world series that's the that's the
late
the i just try to do that the yankees a
lot of these guys but
going to putin going to putin so
you know my mother's side they're from
russia okay so
their their bible was karl marx
communist manifesto so they're from the
stalin lenin era they escaped or baku
azerbaijan armenia and they came to
pandar pahlavi which is right on caspian
sea north
uh iran and it's a few hours away from
tehran and we heard stories you know
about who lenin was who stalin was who
these guys were etc etc and then here in
america if if you drop the name putin to
the average person and let's just say
david goes on the streets there's a man
on the street in new york or he doesn't
miami if you ask a hundred people who's
putin they're gonna say what dictator
he's this he's that he's a murderer he's
gonna say all this stuff about him right
now you have actually interviewed with
them i don't know how many hours you
guys were to get it was a project that
took quite a while to do
and four of these interviews were
launched so who is putin to you having
spent one-on-one time with them how
different is it than what we see on tv
how he's portrayed
you probably don't want to hear it but
he's the son of russia in the sense that
he has russian interests or foremost in
his mind as he as would any leader in
any country whether it's the philippines
or
taiwan or this or that i mean he is
cares about his country and he serves it
that's the way he and that's why he's
he's there because people feel that he's
there and it's they talk about he's he's
a tyrant but he wouldn't stay in office
in russia the russia that i know and
many people would agree with this that
it if he was a
monster which is pictured in the west
he'd be out of office because it
wouldn't work
they they have this ins
indirect democracy so to speak the
people are not happy things are bad the
guy is out and that's what happened to a
few leaders
so
on that point you know i i went at it
without preconceptions like we talked
about earlier
i'd heard all the stories and of course
i spoke to people who
told me other things among them was
stephen cohen who became i became very
friendly with cohn was the i think the
leading sovietologist in our country he
was studied russia he he gave me uh
point by point all the descriptions of
these murders and who possibly did them
but certainly it would be ridiculous for
putin to have done them because the
motive would have come right back on him
he would have been i mean it's beyond
the narrative is so
poorly constructed against him by the
cia and it's been a narrative there for
what is it 20 years now
20 years of lying and blaming everything
on russia you have to be
you have to be a little bit more
fair-minded you have to be open to say
that is it possible that oh that russia
has done all this and and we're the good
guys it's like a good versus bad
scenario it feels like a you know
john wayne movie it's not
we're not john wayne
we're uh we have been
trying to destabilize russia since uh
1917 actually when we sent an army there
in 1918 19 with the the 16 other armies
to take apart the revolution woodrow
this great democrat woodrow wilson sent
the army then again we we didn't
recognize russia until roosevelt
recognized russia in 33. roosevelt is
the one who tried and he reached out to
stalin and he met with him
he met with him and he liked him and he
said uncle joe they had fun together
they laughed they met in iran they got
along and roseville had a plan if he
lived after april 45 to bring russia
into the into this grand alliance that
he wanted he saw un grand alliance it
was a very
it was a very uh
strong good picture of the world england
would be
u.s china russia
it was a tragedy he died in april
because truman came in and
he reversed the planes like johnson
after kennedy he reversed the policy
with the russia right away
right away they had a horrible meeting
stalin was felt that this was uh the
opening was over and of course stalin is
not saying he's he's he was a tyrant
that was a tyrant and he was very and he
was a murderer and he killed people but
that doesn't change the effort that
russia made in world war ii and the
sacrifice they made and how they helped
us too so you have to balance the good
and the bad the people who hate russia
of course point to stalin is the most
evil man of all time worse than hitler
so they make a whole scenario about him
but they ignore what the russians
contribution was to world war ii and
stalin frankly held that country
together at that time he was a tough guy
but uh you
you have to make you sometimes you have
to lie in bed with people like that to
uh to get what you need
and america has to be realistic about it
you can't be a
child about comic book heroes so anyway
putin is listen i spent uh i'm limited i
spent uh
four trips maybe 30 hours with a man so
and the result you should see it i hope
you see it it's called the putin
interviews it's four hours long
four hours long it was on show time it
still is
and it's available on through other
channels too you can get it probably on
amazon you can rent it or you can buy it
it's a it's he he answers these
questions that we're dealing with today
ukraine foremost in his mind at that
point this was 2000 right after 14 this
was 16 area and he tells me the whole
story from his point of view
even down to who's firing who who are
the people who are firing shots at medan
it's not it's not pro-russian forces
because they're firing from buildings
occupied by the protesters it's a it's
people who are snipers who are firing at
the crowd killing both policemen and and
protesters
that's the whole point you create it was
like the same thing that happened in
venezuela back
around that time that's a cia technique
color revolution then you then you have
the violence the violence breaks out
somebody's killing somebody but you kill
from both sides you create this
disturbance
and
they killed a lot of cops they killed
protesters and that kicked off
so who did it
who was firing from those buildings
there was
lots of stories about the neo-nazi gangs
that were coming into kiev from the west
and from the west of ukraine
it's most likely them i mean it probably
was them it may have been some foreign
mercenaries too
so there was all that violence is what
creates that mood for
for change so they throw the president
out illegally they they don't have an
election you they we install this guy uh
uh
the other victim whoever he was victoria
newland is there from the state
department she's the leader of the
neocon faction uh and the american
ambassador it's all written we got the
recordings they're talking about getting
rid and she even says [ __ ] the eu
because the eu wants to do it more
legally you know
frankly france and switzerland were
playing a role here very and germany
were playing a very important role in
trying to make this a transition that
was democratic
because they were going to have an
earlier election didn't happen because
of the violence
the nazis have much more power in
ukraine than you think the united states
denies it because they say zolensky is a
jew and that's their motivation for
saying well how can they be neo-nazi
that's nonsense neo-nazis were there way
before zolensky and zolensky had no
power in fact when he became president
he had to make a deal with them
he had to make a deal with them because
they're tough people they're not gonna
they are telling the president what to
do
you cannot change the ukraine policies
you have the united states telling you
what to do and you have the neo-nazis
telling you what to do and what it's
it's disgusting that the united states
is
condones it doesn't mention him doesn't
talk about him but basically condones
what the nazis the neo-nazis are doing
in ukraine that's what's sick
really sick so when you talk about all
that putin is talking about that he
talks about ukraine and he talks a lot
about nato
this was back then he saw it
for him it's you're putting my back
against the wall i'm going you're
pushing me
that you're strangling me we're
surrounding them
we made the baltics
very aggressive towards them sweet
sweden finland uh poland has been we put
anti-ballistic missiles in poland that's
horrible and romania
and these missiles can be adapted to an
offensive weaponry
and
in five minutes could be in moscow you
see from from their point of view it's
it they they feel the squeeze you put
his back up against the wall what are
you doing you're going to create a state
either where
he's going to go to war and he's going
to fight back and he's got the nuclear
weapons to do so
they're pre they're they're crude
weapons but they're they're very big
strong weapons hypersonic missiles
we have very
refined weapons we have we have great
weapons too but who wouldn't want to be
there in that war it's it's it's not a
war that makes any sense for the world
and uh he's pushed we're pushing his
into the wall either that or else we'll
get what we want which is
regime change
bring in some guy like yeltsin was in
1990 who would work with us
basically cannibalize the country and
allow
allow their resources to be exploited
that's interesting what you're what
you're saying oliver because
one of the techniques that was deployed
at the fall of the berlin wall remember
was reagan putting the pershing missiles
in germany
i remember and it really freaked out
gorbachev oh yeah and they went to
iceland and gorbachev said what do you
want me to do
and reagan said you should have said yes
and so
looking back to the lens
is this kind of that you think
what i'm hearing is you see a playbook
here absolutely absolutely never changed
the the neoconservatives have kept this
playbook alive if you remember the
project for the new american century
that was the the plan to attack all
these countries and get and clean out
the middle east first of all
uh it was a husband of victoria newland
kagan robert kagan who was one of the
project founders you can go up to robert
kagan and you can go to victoria newland
on your board there
these are the villains
these are the foster dullesters and
allen questions of the modern era
that her and her husband uh
you know she's a beauty she's a beauty
[Laughter]
no i when i see a face like that it
makes me
really
and i i i voted for biden and because i
thought you know then uncle joe that he
mellowed you know he can't be as bad as
he used to be when she was for every war
america was in remember he was like he
was a cold warrior
he's never but he never changed he never
he he should be curbing these people
instead of appointing them to
she comes from the hillary clinton
period she uh he's inherited that and he
he let her become under secretary of
state for that region and that is a huge
mistake huge mistake but show me kagan
her her uh
her husband i wonder what their what
their days are like and what their
dinners are like
well there's some you're describing some
very strange bedfellows and what's
interesting you were talking about you
know it's an easy connection one that
i've heard and it seemed very logical
about eisenhower's prophecy about the
military industrial complex
in his departing addresses he brought it
up more than once
uh apparently kennedy took that very
very seriously or already had
predilection in that direction but then
you're talking about the um the
intelligence
the intelligence community and the
ability to get the go-ahead
isn't it interesting that alan dulles
ends up on the warren commission
that's what
i think you can answer that for yourself
it's like the fox is investigating the
chicken coop yeah it's not really a
question it was kind of a reflective
thing
alan dulles did everything in his power
first of all he didn't have a job so he
was he was available to come in for
every session none of the other
members of the commission were able to
do that
dulles uh
supervised followed that thing
everything from the cia was blocked of
importance nothing got through
the the biggest crime of all was that he
didn't even bother to tell the his
fellow commissioners that we had tried
to assassinate castro
didn't tell them so they didn't even
know about our assassination programs
when they started this commission so
where are they going to go
they're in the dark but they didn't have
they had an agenda anyway
it was going to be straightjacket was
jayhadgerhoover said three bullets six
seconds a crazy assassin uh a communist
type
and that was it it was closed that was
over it was there was no investigation
beyond that everything had to fit that
scenario
can i revisit one thing you just said a
second ago
i i don't want to gloss over it because
i i mean listening to you i'm being
educated beyond but you said that you
voted for biden and yeah yeah i assume
you didn't do that like well you mean a
choice okay well that's what i wanted to
ask you is that why do you feel like
your back was against the wall like if
you didn't have a choice to put it in
putin in terms of frankly and then what
did you expect from him and what did you
know what do you what grade would you i
guess give him now i you know i'm a
sucker for believing i'm an optimist and
i believe that he reached a certain age
a 78 then he's a little more mature and
that he sees the bigger picture
and in this case ukraine he is cr he's
making a big mistake
a big mistake he's oh he thinks he's off
the hook he's he looks like the good guy
now with all this anti-russian thing but
when we get to a deeper place which is
where it's going to go
and this thing gets harder and harder
for americans
and they might be
we're not passed any war yet the war
could expand
that certainly zolensky would like the
war to expand because he would sacrifice
the world in order to save ukraine he
doesn't care about us he doesn't care
about he sees his whole thing as a
crusade as a jihad
biden has given him the go ahead
to do this
biden is the one who should be calming
this situation down he should be
speaking to putin speaking to zolansky
calming it down being a statesman
instead of a ideologue
this is a time for a
uh a kennedy this is a time that's what
kennedy did with khrushchev this is a
time for statesmen a statesman you know
like charles de gaulle somebody who
really has a picture of the world i i
was hoping macron of france could have
some effect
but
you can't get through the ukrainian u.s
connection that's the problem but beyond
ukraine i mean what's happening there's
no beyond ukraine right now because it's
stuck there there's a disconnect the
americans see russia as a evil and they
don't understand and the russian
position which is crazy why can't a
statesman understand
what russia is thinking
putin is fighting for his life
you can get rid of him but whoever takes
his place will probably be tougher
because they know that they're up
against it okay what let them give up
let's say okay give up so what do you do
if you want to give up
all right then you put your put your put
nato in into ukraine put put missiles
into ukraine fine you can put them right
on our border we'll take all the
refugees you can give us and uh there'll
be another confrontation when you make
your next move
and one of the things you often hear
though is well this would be different
under trump
nothing happened with ukraine and russia
under trump
that's not true that's not true at all
trump on the contrary is a very strange
guy he was making sounds about putin
when he came in and i was hoping that
there'd be some dayton but as he got
more and more pressure for his uh
russiagate which was a joke but it was a
serious serious accusation that was of
course political too putting pressure on
trump not allowing him to get anything
done
with this pressure from russiagate for
what two years that was insane that he
was a russian agent all that stuff no
one i mean if you were thinking it's it
was so ridiculous and i asked putin
about that too and
putin practically laughed it was he
knows that it's not possible but they
they pictured trump as a tool as a
manchurian candidate or something as a
result
he became very anti-russian too in the
sense that he was passed every single
sanction against russia that was asked
put onto him by congress
check his record on russia he did
everything they wanted
and then recently i i saw yesterday or
two days ago one of his comments which
was insane he said
he would he would he would he's not a
coward like uh like buying something
like biden is a weakling something like
that implying that he would be much
tougher which means what war nuclear war
to my mind last thing before we wrap up
here um
what what so you said that the right
thing to do right now for biden is to be
a statesman
um
to be a statesman right thing for him to
do right now is to be a statesman reach
out to putin have a meeting with him sit
down have that conversation well he also
has to take the he has to deal with
ukrainian and you have to deal with a
neo-nazi issue he's got to deal with the
ukraine administration the way
that country is run
there
i think if you can obviously if we could
have reached a deal where we could they
could split east and west it would it
would but it's very hard to do that
yeah that's not going to be easy to do
though i don't think that's the
direction it's going to go you saw they
made him an offer and zielinski turned
it down
but he promised them that he's going to
cool off the negotiation with nato and
he's kind of backing out from getting
closer to nato it seems like uh
you know who who is who's putin most uh
annoyed and upset with for him to get to
this point is he seen it from your
opinion as being opportunistic saying
i'd rather do it under biden because of
how they handled afghanistan and the
taliban got what they wanted rather than
trump is it more purely his just being
uh opportunistic or did somebody do
something with a proxy nato biden u.s
somebody pissed him off to say this is
the time to go he didn't get pissed off
no he just
he doesn't get pissed off what struck me
about him over these years that i met
him was how cool he was how rational
he's a he's a chess player he does he
looks at politics as without emotion and
that's i think one of his powerful
you know you you talk to you talk about
him as if he's some villain in the west
but the truth is if you go to africa and
you go to the middle east and parts of
asia you'd be surprised that he's
admired as one of the best statesmen of
this era
but unfortunately we've put him in this
it's a disconnect between america and
partly because of our propaganda it's
very powerful
i'm surprised by the eu's tough
i mean basically you understand biden
made this move using ukraine but it
helps him with eu and nato it makes
their
dependence on the united states even
tighter
so and he was worried about losing their
control of the eu sector because they're
economically much more involved with
russia and china than than we would like
what's what's the worst thing last
question what's the worst thing putin is
capable of doing the worst thing
and yes the worst thing he's capable of
doing if we keep playing the strategy
there's no way there's no hope down that
road okay so if we put more pressure and
more pressure which is what happened
recently he's going to fight back
and
will he blow up the world
why god i
what does he i mean
is he supposed to sacrifice russia to
the world perhaps that's the ultimate
question right are you willing to become
leave office uh be whatever be shamed
would you be willing to let russia
become
open to nato or whatever you wanted you
know
something like that but that would be a
complete capitulation wouldn't it
and that would be the end of the uh
the russians are very proud people
the ones that i saw they're very proud
their country is
i said he's a son of russia he's not a
communist he's not an evil bench he's a
son of russia he's very lower class came
from a poor family his parents were in
the war i mean the whole story it's just
and not he's not a kgb agent that's
another ridiculous thing you hear that
george bush was in the cia but we don't
say he was a cia agent but that's an
american denigration as if he's still
thinking like his kgb agent out of james
bond and he wants to he wants to kill
people it's it's childish
he's a russian patriot
and if we see him that way
you can start to deal with them
but there's so russia phobia in this
country it's
as i say going back to 1970 18.
i wish
you need a statesman you need american
statesman
who's the last one kennedy
do we have a current one right now
gorbachev is still alive i wish he'd
come out of he's old i met him a few
times
i like gorbachev but i don't think the
american side would even
even deal with them i mean they wouldn't
understand what his contribution has
been to the world i thought 1986 was
going to be a new era when he came in
who was gorbachev he came out of nowhere
to me
and it was a beautiful moment in time
have you thought about reaching out to
him and having an interview with him or
no
i mean he knows what's going on i mean
would the americans accept him as as an
arbitrator here can you put a picture of
him right now michael gorbachev
if you had george schultz and gorbachev
and if george was still alive they would
be the perfect older men is there anyone
in america right now that is the perfect
statesman that could could maybe step up
well he's not going to be biden and
according to you
yeah maybe obama
you think obama maybe
although he's
you know he's so he's so aware of the
popular will
that he would he would he bucket
uh so we're coming to the end of the
interview and i got to tell you uh this
last uh however long we've been together
felt like five minutes what makes you
very interesting is the following
so
someone's listening to you the audience
is like oh
you know
he just took uh
a liberal lyndon johnson he says he's a
bad guy oh no no no he said kennedy is
known the reagan's bad no but hillary
clinton he threw her under but says
obama's good but maybe obama is there
but then maybe
but the beautiful thing about this is
the fact that somebody cannot put you in
any box
so nobody can say he's just a
conservative he's a republican he's a
democrat he's an independent no you went
all over the place so i hope the
audience is being very fair and folks
this is what i would suggest to you
share this with others and watch it with
your family sit down and watch this with
your family and say what do you think
about what he has to say with the amount
of experience he has outside of that i
got two other things i want to challenge
you to do number one ukraine on fire
officially was taken off of youtube i
think yet uh 20 uh two days ago was
taken off of youtube but you can watch
it on other platforms go watch that
and then number two is go buy his book
uh uh that's out the story of
uh uh chasing the light yeah chase on
the light the story of oliver stone go
get that as well and then outside of
that uh man this was a treat i gotta
tell you this was such a treat having
you on here thank you so much okay
revisit it for sure those i'm i'm
posting all of that but go watch all of
that uh oliver stone thank you for
coming out gee well it's been fun
talking to you and thank you for your
open mind appreciate you thank you this
has been great thank you everybody thank
you adam and tom bye bye bye bye
that flew by
you